hey everyone welcome to this live
session by simply learn in today's
session you will learn the top ten
artificial intelligence technologies in
2020 and how it is going to impact our
business and our lives but before we
proceed make sure to subscribe to our
channel and hit the bell icon to never
miss an update also we have a quiz in
this video and you could be one of the
lucky winners to win an Amazon voucher
so stay tuned for that now we look at
the important technologies in artificial
intelligence that will help in solving
business problems then we look at the
companies that are using these
technologies and lastly we look at how
simply learned can help you become a
certified artificial intelligence
professional so at number 10 we have
marketing automation marketers say
artificial intelligence is a thing of
the future but it's not it is playing a
significant role in marketing efforts
and is taking marketing automation to
the next level so marketing automation
refers to software platforms and
technologies designed for marketing
departments and organizations to
efficiently market products and multiple
channels online it can be done via
emails social media platforms different
websites to automate repetitive tasks
artificial intelligence is been used to
automate work and produce a better yield
automated customer segmentation product
recommendation campaign management
improved customer experience predictive
lead scoring I have been done using AI
driven tools such as market o Eloqua
HubSpot Yandex
Google Analytics etc marketing
automation with AI allows you to
understand who your customers really are
and enhance customer satisfaction at
nine we have decision management
decision management is a discipline with
set of tools and techniques that allow
businesses to make decisions it involves
systems that go beyond descriptive and
predictive analysis to specify the best
actions to take or to compute a judgment
or conclusion that solves a problem it
is part of prescriptive analytics which
enables organizations to model
operational decisions and automatically
trigger a response artificial
intelligence systems can insert rules
and logic into AI systems in order to
use them for training maintenance and
cuny there are mainly three steps to
apply decision management principles
first his decision identification and
decision modeling second is a
development of a system or service that
autumn
all parts of the decision and finally we
have ongoing monitoring and management
of the decision to keep the business
rules and predictive analytics models
used up to date it helps in making quick
decisions and avoid risks these systems
are widely implemented in the financial
sector health care trading insurance
ecommerce etcetera at number 8 we have
distilled - in digital Quinn is a
software representation of assets and
processes that are used to understand
predict and optimize performance in
order to achieve improved business
outcomes Digital - in consists of three
components a data model a set of
algorithms and a knowledge base some of
the important benefits of digital - in
our increase reliability and
availability reduced risk lower
maintenance costs and improved
production it uses a virtual replica of
physical devices that can run
simulations before actual devices are
built and deployed digital twin is used
in 3d modeling to create digital
companions for physical objects it is
also used in manufacturing automobile
sector retail healthcare etc General
Electric Siemens Cisco Systems Microsoft
and Oracle are some of the vendors of
digital twin at number seven we have AI
optimized Hardware as data is growing
day by day and the need for deriving
insights from this data is increasing a
conventionalized chip cannot support
artificial intelligence models a new
generation of artificial intelligence
chips has been developed for neural
networks deep learning and computer
vision hardware has been designed and
optimized for AI workloads sophisticated
CPUs and GPUs are being built to handle
scalable workloads today's systems have
achieved improved AI performance by
infusing machine learning capabilities
with high bandwidth CPUs GPUs
specialized AI accelerators and
high-performance networking equipment
companies like Nvidia Qualcomm and AMD
our manufacturing chips that can perform
complex AI calculations IBM Research is
developing new devices and hardware
architectures to support the processing
power and speed that AI requires to
realize its full potential at 6 we have
robotic process automation
robotic process automation or RPE is the
use of specialized computer programs
known as software robots to automate and
standardize repeatable business
processes governed by business logic and
structured inputs RPE aims to automate
business processes using RPA tools
we can configure software or a robot to
capture and interpret applications for
processing a transaction manipulating
data triggering responses and
communicating with other digital systems
it provides organizations with the
ability to reduce staffing costs and
human error some of the popular tools in
our PA are blue prism uipath and
automation anywhere using these tools a
large number of processes can be easily
automated without having programming
skills to configure a software robot
some of the companies using our PR
Walmart AT&T Austin young American
Express etc at five we have machine
learning machine learning has become a
buzz in the industries these days it is
a branch of artificial intelligence that
is based on the idea that systems can
learn from vast volumes of data identify
patterns and make decisions with minimal
human intervention one of the key
advantages of machine learning is when
models are exposed to new data they are
able to adapt independently it uses
algorithms and statistical models to
perform specific tasks supervised
unsupervised and reinforcement learning
are the different types of machine
learning algorithms fraud detection
stock price analysis weather prediction
product recommendation are some of the
examples of machine learning JP Morgan
Amazon Google IBM Walmart and Intel are
some of the companies that use machine
learning on a regular basis at 4:00 we
have deep learning
now deep learning is a subset of machine
learning and a branch of artificial
intelligence it uses complex algorithms
to learn from data and improve with
experience while machine learning uses
simpler concepts and structured data
deep learning works with artificial
neural networks which are designed to
imitate how humans think and learn
artificial neural networks drive deep
learning by processing data in multiple
layers to produce the desired output
deep learning is been widely used for
image classification language
translation speech recognition facial
recognition building chat boards cancer
detection etc self-driving cars is
another popular application of deep
learning Pinterest
Spotify Facebook Google Twitter Baidu
and IBM are some of the companies using
deep learning to use their business at
number three we have Internet of Things
Internet of Things or IOT is another
technology
that is very much in demand these days
it refers to the billions of physical
devices around the world that can now be
connected to the Internet all collecting
and sharing data Kevin Ashton coined the
phrase Internet of Things in 1999
although it took at least another decade
for the technology to catch up with the
vision any physical object can be
transformed into an IOT device if it can
be connected to the Internet the term
IOT is mainly used for devices that
won't generally be expected to have an
internet connection and that can
communicate with the network
independently of human action a report
from Samsung says the need to secure
every connected device by 2020 is
essential the forms open economic
document says there is a very clear
danger the technology is running ahead
of the game a form said more than 7.3
billion devices will need to be made
secure by their manufacturers before
2020 IOT has been widely used to create
smart homes smart cities smart retail
and is being used in healthcare as well
Cisco who I sa p IBM ge digital and
Siemens are some of the most popular IOT
software solutions and services
companies worldwide at number two we
have natural language processing natural
language processing of NLP is a branch
of artificial intelligence that gives
computers the ability to read understand
and derive meaning from human languages
today NLP is booming
thanks to the huge improvements in
access to data and the increase in
computational power which has allowed
practitioners to achieve meaningful
results in areas like healthcare media
finance and human resources
NLP includes many different techniques
for interpreting human language ranging
from statistical and machine learning
methods to rule-based and algorithmic
approaches companies like yahoo and
google filter and classify your emails
with NLP by analyzing text in emails
that flow through their servers Amazon's
Alexa and Apple's Siri and examples of
intelligent voyage driven systems that
use NLP to respond to vocal prompts and
do everything such as find a particular
shop tell us the weather forecast
suggest the best route to the office or
turn on the lights at home companies
like winter light labs are making huge
improvements in the treatment of
Alzheimer's disease by monitoring
cognitive impairment through speech
Stanford University
robot a chatbot therapist with the aim
to help people with anxiety and other
disorders grammerly semantic machines
SoundHound and together some of the
companies that use natural language
processing finally at number one we have
virtual agents virtual agent is a
computer-generated animated artificial
intelligence virtual character that
serves as an online customer service
representative they can give relevant
advice and sustain an informative
conversation with consumers it is more
like a software agent that can perform
tasks or services for an individual
based on commands or questions
the term chat bot is used to refer to
virtual assistants an example of a
typical virtual agent is Luis which is
the virtual agent of EB virtual agents
can be integrated into many types of
platforms like Amazon Alexa smart
speakers such as Amazon echo or Google
home some of the best virtual assistant
companies are pre l2 would boast tasks
bullet and in televised now if you are
looking for a career in artificial
intelligence machine learning deep
learning or RP and you find potential in
these domains well you're at the right
place simply learn can help you with it
we provide you with wide range of
courses in all these categories so let
me go to the course page and show you
what courses to be offered
so I'll log in to simple and calm and
under all courses by check for AI and
machine learning you can see there are a
number of courses that we provide let me
go ahead and explore this category
you
as you can see we have a number of
courses under artificial intelligence
and machine learning
so you get a lot of options here and
depending on your requirements you can
take up any appropriate course you can
check out the program overview and its
key features to get a better
understanding let me explore artificial
intelligence engineers course this is a
master's program that is developed in
collaboration with IBM you can see on
the right this course provides you with
seven modules where you will learn about
AI machine learning deep learning with
chaos and tensorflow
natural language processing and finally
you will get to work on an AI capstone
project let me go back I'll show you
another course which you can opt for
this is very much in demand in the
market so this is our postgraduate
program in AI and machine learning which
is in collaboration with Purdue
University and IBM so if I scroll down
you can see the learning path here and
the things that you are going to learn
so this course will teach you Python for
data science machine learning advanced
deep learning in computer vision NLP
reinforcement learning and many more now
you can also offer a few electives in
this course some of the key features of
this program are you get a Purdue
Illumina Association membership
enrollment and simply lands job assist
you will get industry recognized IBM
certificates 25 plus hands-on projects
on integrated labs then you get 450 plus
R so blended learning
you'll get Purdue postgraduate program
certification once you complete it and
certain capstone projects in three
domains now let's get to the exciting
part the quiz but you could win an
Amazon voucher here is an easy question
for you to answer which of the following
is an example of machine learning below
are the options a web analytics be data
migration C fraud detection or is it D
smart homes guys put your answers along
with your email id in the chat section
or comment section you could be one of
the lucky winners to win an Amazon
voucher we will announce the winners
name next week on Monday the 2nd of
March in the comment section and send
you the Amazon voucher through email so
I can see there are a lot of questions
our viewers are asking let me take a few
of them so one question I have is how is
digital 2 induced in automobile sector
so actually digital twins can be used in
the automobile sector for creating the
virtual model of a connected vehicle it
captures the behavioral and operational
data of the vehicle and helps in
analyzing the overall vehicle
performance as well as the connector
features another question that I can see
on the chat window is what are the
benefits of our PA so RP actually as a
technology reduces human error it
integrates across multiple platforms it
improves customer experience and it
allows business users to build BOTS on
their own and there's no programming
skills necessary at all another question
which again see here is what is the
scope of AI in healthcare so healthcare
is one sector which has got a huge
impact because of the advancement in AI
technologies you can now have early
detection of cancer cells you can now
identify if a person has diabetic
retinopathy which is actually a diabetes
complication that affects your eyes he
is also been majorly used for drug
development and medical imaging we will
have a Q&A session guys put your
questions in the chat section and we
will reply to them by a chat
you
and with that we have reached the end of
this session I hope you guys found this
informative and helpful
thank you for watching keep learning and
stay tuned for more from simply lone
you